قسم التحقيق الاول على وجه الخصوص
القضايا الهامة لقسم التحقيق
روسيا في جمهورية إنغوشيا
حسب مواد البحث التشغيلي
الأنشطة الواردة من FSB في روسيا
في جمهورية إنغوشيا
وقد بدأت إجراءات جنائية ضده
أربعة من سكان الجمهورية المشتبه بهم
ارتكاب جرائم تحت
الجزء الثاني من المادة 205 مباشرة 5 ش القاهرة
المشاركة في أنشطة إرهابية
تنظيم الجزء 5 من المادة 33 من الجزء 2
المادة 205 مباشرة 5 المساعدة على المشاركة
الأنشطة الإرهابية
المنظمات من المادة 205 مباشرة 6
القانون الجنائي للاتحاد الروسي
عدم الإبلاغ عن الجرائم أثناء
تم إنشاء التحقيق الأولي
أن اثنين من سكان مدينة جمهورية سونزي
إنغوشيا كونها أتباع
حركة دينية راديكالية
انضم إلى الدولية
تنظيمات الدولة الإسلامية
والتي حسب القرار
المحكمة العليا للاتحاد الروسي
معترف به كإرهابي
يمين الولاء والقادة على المشاركة
من هؤلاء الأشخاص في أنشطة محظورة
إرهابي دولي
كانت المنظمة التحضير و
ارتكاب جرائم
طبيعة إرهابية